first of all again an introduction on
what we're about specifically we are
challenging many of the interpretations
physical interpretations of mathematical
physics more than most of them were
challenging them all we're saying none
of them have anything to do with reality
and the main reason here is that there
in the movement of concepts okay and
we're in the movement of objects we
think physics has to be mediated by
objects so here I'm gonna show the
bottom line for us we're saying that oh
and I'm gonna move a little bit aside so
that you can see that a little better
there that's the basic system we have
two atoms interconnected by a rope okay
two twine threads the twine threads you
can think about them as DNA like in fact
one of the theories or I guess guesses
intuitions is that DNA copied its form
from light that's why DNA is helical and
so is you know just like light is the
atoms pump back and forth and they
essentially transmit a torsion from atom
to atom and the torsion travels in both
directions that's light if we take light
out of there now we're gonna put
something else we're gonna put we're
gonna give a little image of gravity
okay and here's gravity the essence of
gravity we're saying as two objects move
together they could be celestial objects
they could be anything here with indeed
on earth and as you can see here there
are five atoms on the cube the left-hand
side of the screen air and one atom
connected to one atom in a cylinder
number six there as the Suman
approaches the cube the ropes that
seemed to pull as one in the first case
now pool independently so they're
essentially pulling as two objects
approach the the ropes fan out and arm
or ropes intervening that's why you have
an acceleration the acceleration of
gravity okay and finally let me remove
this one not finding there's two more
sorry we here we have magnetism this is
our version of magnetism we have two
magnets and we're not divided into north
and south as convention would have it
they're divided into top and bottom we
divide the atom length the magnet
lengthwise we have a top part I got just
the top part in the bottom part and the
atoms on the top in this case are all
the blue curved arrows there that you
can see they're twirling clockwise
whereas the bottom ones are twirling
counter clockwise so what happens
there's as the Rose those Rose on the
top of violet pink ones on the top
they're turning around and they're
swinging threads around themselves and
that is what goes around a magnet that
forms a so-called magnetic field as the
threads of the top part come down the
threads of the second magnet top part
come up and that's where they have this
attraction this friction these walls of
threads that form the magnetic field
attract the other field and the bottom
one is exactly in Reverse they're moving
counterclockwise as one comes up the
other one comes down and so we have
attraction on all four corners of the
Magnus where they are facing each other
and that's the basic math mechanism that
we're proposing for magnetic attraction
I don't I haven't brought today the
magnetic repulsion but if you turn one
of the magnets around let's say the one
on the right
you turn it exactly 180 degrees around
you will see that they will hit each
other and they will push each other away
that's the mechanism and how does this
differ from what is being suggested by
mainstream while mainstream proposes
essentially that all atoms are Islands
they're discrete particles and not only
atoms but subatomic particles are also
discrete particles so whereas the rope
hypothesis that you can see they're all
atoms are interconnected so the question
we have for the math fist-sized side or
the objection we have against it is that
you know if you're gonna have one of
those little balls pull out on another
little ball you better have some kind of
mediator and if you don't have a
physical mediator to put in there you're
in effect tacitly
putting in there spirits because there's
no way a little ball can influence
another ball at a distance without a
mediator and that's essentially where
the two proposals differ the rope
hypothesis from the what I call the
particle hypothesis which it turns out
to make matters worse they're not really
particles the word particle means
something different in mathematical
physics it's used as a little ball
whenever they want to illustrate the
physical interpretation but when you
push these people against the wall
they'll deny and say well it's not
really a little ball as you would think
a corpuscle as Newton thought about it
it's a quantity so they're moving in
abstraction a point particle a zero
dimensional nothing and so you got to
keep that in mind also but assuming that
in the best-case scenario that these are
three dimensional balls
the only way one can influence another
at a distance is with a mediator without
that your tacit be implicitly
introducing a spirit in there okay and
again that's why I refer to it as
mathematicians they're doing it with
magic black magic